leann Bailey's father was put on
universal credit last year but she says
whenever he rang the helpline he was
told to go online we dumped not having a
computer all the up was a mobile phone
he didn't allow to log on to the journal
he went quite sure what to do if he
needed to speak to somebody you had to
go through the journal then once you
message then that send you a text
message to say check your journal and
every day was just getting stressed for
that when all the actual what to do was
just pop in sit down chat somebody in
July last year Brian Bailey took his own
life he was 59 in October a former
universal credit case manager lifted the
lid on life inside the system so there
was something called the deflection
script which is within your booth they
are Tarpley said agents were given
scripts used to deflect claimants away
from the help lines at the time the
Department for Work and Pensions said
those claims were completely false we've
been given this internal DWP document in
which advice is given to call handlers
on how to get claimants off the phone
and online as quickly as possible and
interestingly it includes two words
deflection script the deflection scripts
the DWP denies ever existed are
discussed here it's revealed that a
deflection script was developed to
support staff and noting its potential
to be controversial adds this will not
be launched as a formal script its
purpose it goes on to ensure deflection
techniques are identified and if anyone
was in doubt about the purpose it
concludes encourage staff to ask what
the claimant is calling for at the
beginning of the call rather than moving
straight to security questions
this may open up the opportunity to
deflect the caller online the documents
were obtained by Labour's Daniel Rowley
I think that it's it's outrageous that
the DWP have first said that there
aren't any scripts and though that I've
seen those scripts and we know that
they're there
and for the department to be trying to
shrug that off again and say it's false
and you know when I see them and see the
words deflection script which the
department have Delap denied it's just
further proof that they're trying to
hide things despite the evidence here
the DWP refused to comment on the
existence of deflection scripts telling
us there has never been a policy to
hurry callers off the phones and
accusations that this is the case are
completely false
call handlers are encouraged to spend as
much time as necessary on the phone and
remind claimants that they are able to
complete certain activities online where
appropriate there was making him go on
the journal there was making him talk to
people via a journal even though he was
talking to all he wanted to do was just
pop in and speak to somebody so to know
that I just think it's disgustin
Universal Credit has been beset with
problems and still is pension secretary
ambhiraj says changes will be made
including making the process more
compassionate to the needs of those
accessing it Nick Martin Sky News